i got something pretty something special
for you
jason mamoa freshly buzzed and showing
off some new body art awesome yeah the
actor debuted a fresh haircut and a
brand new head tattoo
i got something pretty something special
for you
this is the first time the internet's
seeing jason who's been known for his
signature long locks since he shaved his
head remember this
so
i'm shaving off the hair oh
man
i've never even felt the wind right
there
jason documented the process on
instagram and revealed it was all an
effort to raise awareness
do it for uh
single-use plastics
i'm tired of these plastic bottles we
got to stop
plastic forks all that just goes into
our land goes into our ocean i'm here in
hawaii right now
and just seeing
things in our ocean it's just so sad so
please
anything you can do
to eliminate single-use plastics in your
lives
help me
now jason and his bold new look tattoo
and all are headed overseas it goes to
new zealand finally again
it's been like two years since uh since
they were able to go because of cove
itself
hawaiian airlines i love you for this
yup by the sounds of it jason's off to
film his new apple tv plus series chief
of war
coming baby
but that's not all jason's got on his
plate the actor is booked and busy i'm
gonna go do fast 10. that's gonna be fun
yeah i'm gonna go do this little small
independent over in london yeah yeah and
uh it's fun i can play the bad guy
which i haven't gotta do for a while i
mean you're usually the superhero mister
not gonna be the bad boy um
the very flamboyant bad boy well i think
you know can handle that role just fine
just fine and then uh after that
something really big going back to
hawaii go back to the homeland so
hopefully that all works out and we'll
be doing that
[Music]